the philippines appears to have elected
former dictator ferdinand marcos son as
its new president marcos junior who goes
by the nickname bongbong had more than
double the votes of his challenger lenny
robredo speaking to his supporters on
tuesday marcos jr urged people to judge
him by his actions and not by his family
history his win marks a return to power
of the marcos family which is accused of
running a brutal dictatorship before a
people power revolution restored
democracy in the eighties on monday he
thanked his supporters for their work
i want to thank you
for all you have done for us
there are thousands of you out there
volunteers
parallel groups
political leaders that have cast their
lot with us
because of their belief
in our message of unity
because of their belief in the
candidates
hundreds of human rights activists and
students have been demonstrating against
the outcome of the poll and what appears
to be a landslide victory for marcos the
protesters clashed with police close to
the officers of the philippines election
committee they are denouncing what they
claimed were irregularities after some
vote counting machines broke
authorities say the number of machines
affected was small many demonstrators
are also angered by the return to power
of the disgraced marcos family with its
history of human rights violations and
fraud
and joining me now for more from manila
is our asia pacific bureau chief georg
matas
how serious are these complaints of a
breakdown in vote counting machines
i came became very clear quickly clear
in the election night that a couple of
those machines one thousand eight
hundred to be exact uh had problems and
broke down in fact i was in a polling
station in naga in the stronghold of
leone uh lenny robredo
and one of those machines where i was in
this in the polling station broke down
so people were given the choice fill in
the election papers and leave them for
others to be fed to the machine once
it's fixed or to wait and many choose to
wait so there were long queues but
overall one has to say
that will not threaten the result uh
ferdinand marcos is up for a historic uh
win and probably an absolute majority in
this election
uh speaking about the choice that voters
had i mean they were basically choosing
between a dictator's son ferdinand
marcos jr or bongbong and the outgoing
vice president and human rights champion
lenny robredo
help us understand what marcos's pitch
was to the public that gave him this
landslide
well he talked about sweeping economic
reforms gifts to the poor and you have
to understand that the philippines were
hard hit in the covet pandemic many
people died a lot of people have been
pushed into poverty further than they
already are so he appealed to those
voters in particular how he will do all
of that
he kept to himself largely because he
didn't attend press conferences he
didn't allow questions
from reporters
and also he talked a lot about unity and
many filipinos uh have said unity is
important particularly after this
election many many said to me look
whoever wins this election
one has to secure uh that there will be
a peaceful a way out of this the
election process and the campaigning has
been so divisive and so polarized that
it will really be the task of the
president to keep peace and to keep the
people together
so george just based on what you are
saying what does this mean for the
philippines going forward how does
president marcos unite this country
that's really a good question beerus and
and many filipinos are keen uh to see
how he's gonna achieve that uh one thing
i think you can expect he's teamed up
with the daughter of the current
president sarah duterte
and seeing that the
the style of her father was a rather
authoritarian style fighting a bloody
war
on drugs many expect that this style
will be continued in the in the marcus
era of the presidency with the return of
a
a
dynasty of politicians from the marcus
era some even fear that it will get
worse others say he cannot afford that
to let that happen but how in all of
this the unity thing will will work with
lenny robredo being really exactly the
opposite
of of marcos uh what will be extremely
interesting to see
jorg matas will leave it there for the
time being thank you so much for joining
us from manila
he may still be an untested leader of a
nation but bongbong marcos is no
stranger to politics his dictator father
ruled the philippines for two decades
until a people's revolt but marcos jr
has managed quite a comeback for a
family once synonymous with abuse and
corruption
[Applause]
celebrations for ferdinand marcos jr on
the streets of manila
[Music]
his likely win would cement his family's
return to power in the philippines
following the revolution that toppled
his late father in 1986.
the elder ferdinand marcos ruled the
philippines as a dictator for two
decades and his tenure was infamous for
its corruption and brutality
for many it was unthinkable that the
marcos clan would ever run for the
highest office again
after returning from exile the marcos
returned to public life in the
philippines with several family members
taking on political positions
many of bongbong's younger supporters
don't connect him to his father's crimes
we believe that bbm is starkly different
from his father
ferdinand
marcos ran his election campaign on
promises of unity but has failed to
explain his policy plans in detail
analysts warned that his administration
will most likely mean more strongman
posturing and less democratic freedoms
and
transparency
joining me now for more analysis on this
is journalist and analyst anna santos
anna help us understand how a country
that overthrew a dictatorship 36 years
ago elects the last dictator's son as
president
well i think disinformation had a lot to
do with it we saw how the marcus
machinery really tried to and
successfully as we can see scrub clean
the legacy of the horrors of martial law
but i think we also have to look at one
other thing that was missing you know
there are no institutions in the
philippines that commit the horrors of
martial law to memory unlike here in
berlin you see it everywhere there's
both acknowledgement and atonement for
the atrocities of world war ii in the
philippines we don't have anything of
that sort so much to document the
horrors of martial law in our textbooks
in our streets we only have it in our
memories and when you have that combined
with disinformation campaign you see
memory is a faulty thing it's easy to
reconstruct it's easy to rewrite and
therefore that's where you have now
marcus jr coming in with his own new
narrative of a rebranding of the marcus
name and what he promises as a campaign
and as a banner of unity for the country
uh but then you also had uh the the same
uh marcos jr going up against lanier
robredo uh his challenger in this
election in 2016 and him losing in the
vice presidential race so so clearly
there are a number of people in the
philippines who can potentially see
through this sort of white washing i
mean
what is it uh
about this vote are people in the
philippines not democracy minded
i think there's also what we have to
understand about the psyche of the
filipino voter you know how we say
voters vote for their stomach yes the
filipino voter also votes for their
stomach but they also so much vote with
their heart
and i think it's an equal measure so
when you think about you know how the
analysts have analyzed the campaign
messages of both marcos and robredo who
are the top runners in this election you
have marcus talking about a campaign of
unity you have a brother talking about
um radical love and how it's more
important to unite amidst the political
hatred and divisiveness when you look at
these two messages and how they resonate
so much with the filipino voter you
think about how the psyche of the
filipino voter is yes what kind of jobs
are you going to give me what is your
political platform but it's also so much
the aspiration of what kind of future
are you going to give me as my leader
it's so much a courtship you know when
you look at the campaigns in the
philippines there's a lot of singing a
lot of dancing a lot of political
promises you know it's a relationship
that a filipino voter wants to be able
to entrust their future to this leader
and when you think about a message that
resonates you have a marcos who has
whitewashed the horrors of his family
brand name and his history and comes
across as now one strategy said it he
looks like a k-pop star and then he
tells you i can give you a feeling of
unity
then that's where you're going to not
only put your heart bearish but also
cast your vote as we have seen in this
last election
speaking about the people who have cast
their vote what about the kind of people
who voted for lenito bredo for instance
the outgoing vice president and a human
rights champion i mean where does that
leave the philippines now
i think it's important to also note that
yeah i've said it in past interviews the
lenny campaign was not a campaign it was
a movement i wish biresh i could tell
you i could make you feel the emotion on
the ground of the robredo campaign and
it's important here to note that the
campaign the organic volunteerism that
spurred the campaign for red for landing
was not just a no
to the marcos s but also a yes to what
leni rabredo represented
she had uh she was as vice president
during the pandemic she was able to
really show that she could deliver
results with her pandemic response that
was tangible that was something that you
could count and track she was able to do
this with the support of people who
poured in their donations and also
private companies who place their trust
in her by also pouring in their
donations to her campaign for uh for a
pandemic response now what does that
tell us that tells us that left us the
filipino people with a sense of what
good governance not only feels like
not only what it looks like but also
that it is possible and therefore since
it's possible the filipino public is now
in a position to demand for it
you